Talking a little bit about Zero 1…
Zero 1 started a long time ago. We were everything you can
imagine in terms of digital media: agency, producer… We did a lot of things.
From 2009, we started makings apps,
and in the process of seeking a better understanding
about how this market works, and what to do with it,
we tried making legal apps, esoteric apps, cinema…
When we got to the children area, we had the luck of
working with Galinha Pintadinha
Which was also in the beginning, they haven’t had launched
their first DVD at that time.
We realized that there was a great chance of growth
and an opportunity to make a video distribution
in this app format.
The idea was to simply make the distribution
of audiovisual content.
We started doing this since the beginning.
We set out to the distribution of VOD channels,
And thinking better, reflecting and
understanding what was happening,
we noticed that something was missing for a
children app.
It was missing the play.
Our solution was to combine audiovisual content
with what we call interactive activities
or minigames.
What would that be?
Coloring
Memory games, puzzles, find-a-match…
What shape is this? What color is this?
and so on.
We had quite a success with this.
Today, we work with approximatively
40 intellectual proprieties
from Brazil and abroad.
We work with the main Brazilian intellectual proprieties:
Galinha Pintadinha, Patati Patatá, Palavra Cantada,
Os Pequerruchos,
and the international ones, such as Masha and the Bear,
which is Russian,
Uchi, from Belgium, The Beet Party
from Australia,
with Korean co-production.
Today we are top browsing in both
platforms in this category.
Let's talk about the Freemail model that people
adopts as a monetization model.
I think everyone here knows what this is;
you let your free app to download.
Eventually, as some in our case
there is some of the free content,
and you monetize it, usually in a
hybrid way, with advertising and networking.
Since 2014, The Premium Model is the
dominant model of the App Stores.
98% of store billing is within this model,
very driven by the gaming market.
The important thing about it is quite obvious,
you have no barrier.
You download the app without having to pay before.
You can test it first and buy it later.
The main focus of this session is the networking.
Here I will talk a little about these three concepts,
which I think are very important for you to make
the path between download and sale.
You need to have a good experience,
you have to engage your user that made the download,
he has to like this, and just from there
he's going to buy something.
Speaking a little about U-EX, it is the thing that
permeates the journey of the people.
Since the first time someone talked about your app,
the first time he visited your App Store list,
you have to imagine that there you have to
believe in love at first sight,
and do your best to sell what
you think is important in your app,
what we use to call Unique Sales Propositions,
trying to state clearly in the listing
what is the value of your app.
What is really important here, as you might have
seen many times here, in the other sessions,
The icon is very important, you have to test it,
especially here, because the children really
look at it with a lot of attention.
Listing
Google and other platforms let you
put a video.
Video is a key issue today.
A lot of people say that video is the new HTML,
it's a thing that, in the future, starting now,
will dominate the internet and the mobile market.
You have the description, the first three lines
which is the first that appears in the store,
they are very important.
And we have to remember something very important,
that we are within the Google environment.
Obviously, browsing.
You have to pay a lot of attention to that,
and also on what we today call ASO, which stands for
AppStore Search Optimization.
Let's say it's the youngest cousin of SO.
In it, you basically apply the same concepts.
In my opinion, you have to pay attention to what, exactly?
To the title,
to the three main lines that appear
and to the keywords.
Next item,
Onboarding
I'm a big fan of this kind of approach when it comes to
getting the person into your product.
You have to invite him to know your
features, what you have to offer,
you have to seduce, you have to conquer.
It is the key point for you to
ask for things like:
if your app uses a microphone, for example,
it's a good point to ask for the requisition to use this,
or the camera, too.
Ask for Opt-In, to push notifications,
which is essential for you to have this channel open
with your user.
And for you, eventually, if the app had a
registration or login process,
here is the place where you should work this.
Going back a bit to the Listing, but...
Actually is no the Listing, I got confused.
There's been a lot of talk about...
the app compatibility.
We have an interesting experience
to be talking about this, because
we believe that...
Obviously,
bad experience gives bad word-of-mouth
and you will mostly get bad reviews,
and in the end, as it was said,
the review is very important in this category.
Parents will pay a lot of attention to what
other parents think about it.
What we perceived is that
a while ago, a lot of negative reviews were coming
from a specific group of devices.
We went to verify this and indeed,
although we always want to have
a universal compatibility,
Sometimes this is not possible depending
on the features your app has.
What did we do?
We took off compatibility fifty-eight devices
and after a while, we managed
to raise our three-star ranking to four.
Because you limited the negative reviews,
the positive reviews ended up standing out.
Another interesting concept here is that...
You have to create an app for everybody.
When you talk about children at this age,
they are the center of attention of the house.
The parents interact together, the uncles,
the grandparents, the relatives,
This child is surrounded by everybody.
This ends up influencing the usage and participation
of the game within the application.
I would want to leave two cool ideas here:
One is the concept that Galinha Pintadinha uses, which is
Uniting generations through music,
because the songs they mostly use are
from a songbook called Popular Songbook.
They are very old songs,
that the grandmothers or the mothers use to know,
practically all the Brazilian people, and now
the foreign people that we are working with.
They seek to bring back these traditional songs,
And that makes the app appreciated by everybody.
Another cool thing is that,
is that I recently heard
the leader of BuzzFeed,
Ze Frank, I believe this is his name,
I don´t remember,
he said that today the content is not done by itself.
Before, you were creating content and
the people they liked this content.
Today you have to think what
content you will create.
The important thing is that the people will
interact with it.
The focus has changed a bit,
it has shifted from who creates it
to whom uses it.
Support
Support is more than a good experience,
it´s a marketing tool.
You are bringing trust, you're together with your user,
you detect problems before they
become a big problem.
And both the interaction, via its own channel,
and the Google reviews,
It is very important that they are
monitored and responded to,
for you to have a successful outcome.
Talking about engagement,
I don´t know anything better, in order to let
the person inside your app,
than giving something for free.
If you already removed the barrier from the beginning, now
you take the barrier from inside.
Open a little part of your content
for using and for tasting.
If you have a coloring book, you give
some coloring pages,
if you have, like in our case,
videos, you give some videos,
so that the person can understand and
use your app, and so on.
And I think it's an elegant thing,
pleasurable, it creates a better relationship.
You get the person to spend more
time inside your app.
Push Notifications, like I said on the Onboarding process.
It´s a thing that we use a lot.
It's a direct channel with the people
that made the download.
You can communicate, bring
the person back to the app
to interact more, this increases your chance
to monetize this user in the future.
Another way to do this,
actually it´s the same way, but
in a different key,
is local notifications.
They are not sent from the outside in,
but they are already inside your app,
the moment in which the person installs it.
This is cool, because you can do what?
In the moment of the installation, you define
some notifications
From that moment on, to take advantage of the
most important moment of the engagement process,
Which is, I would say, the first weeks,
or the first hours, is the moment that people remember
having downloaded it, they are using it,
or used it yesterday and you can try to engage
the person in the moment with this type of activity.
Localization
This is a different idea that everyone talked about,
which is also important with regard to
location by language.
For us it's a key thing, because we're
talking about music.
It´s even more complex than for other
types of apps.
But here I want to highlight one point;
that children from the whole world are very much alike.
In this phase of life, they have the same experiences,
they are getting to know the world.
They are wondering what is yellow,
what is white, what is green, square, circle...
And you can use this similarity, so you can manage to
expand your product in the whole world.
That is... actually, talking about the application market
it's actually what you want.
Content Refresh
I think that, together with the free content, is one of the
best ways for you to bring the person back,
of you holding back the people who downloaded it.
Is it to change your app, let it live, because the app
is a living organism.
It has to evolve, if it doesn´t evolve
it will get stuck.
One thing that sometimes you may not even notice:
as you can see here,
Here is a chart of some of our apps,
which had two updates
upcoming
In the case here, I think thre were two languages,
I think, I do not know, Mexican and Portuguese.
And you realize that you can raise your
average revenue threshold to another level,
meaning that when you renew
your content, you change the revenue threshold.
Monetization, let's talk a little bit about what matters.
I think, when you've managed to win the person
and it's her goal to buy something,
Nothing better for you than having price options.
In our experience, we sell videos
with ninety-nine cents.
We sell the collection by six and ninety-nine
and all collections for twelve.
You get to choose a number...
You reach various kinds of pocket, let's say.
Going back to this concept of packages,
it's what I'm going to talk about in the end, now that we
are in ... this here is retail
It´s retail you know, take three, pay two,
is a way for you to increase your average ticket
and reach more people who eventually
want to buy the...
They want to buy the full content,
but they have doubts because of the price.
Users are the best prospects, it´s much easier,
it´s also known retail technique.
It´s way easier to sell to whom
already bought from you,
than to somebody that doesn´t know your product.
This is easy, obviously.
And you have to take advantage of this
characteristic of people, right?
They feel confident, they may have already bought it,
they already know what it is, and they'll want to buy it again.
Sales
Once more, retail.
You have to take advantage of it in all the ways,
you have to prepare for it.
There are few times a year with this opportunity,
that you can grow your revenue,
give peaks of three to five times,
and after, to even have a positive residual
for some time.
So, sales is the time to work and
try to sell more.
Retail again.
All the sales techniques
that you can possibly know.
I come from the advertising market,
I used to work with sales and i know
what it is: looks like it doesn´t, but it works.
What?
From - to
Price cut, this for that,
Splash discount.
All this type, this tool that comes
from the retail and sales.
You have to take advantage in the time of
making your sales screen.
Here is perhaps the tip the most
difficult to achieve,
which is to find certain points of your app
that with small changes,
you will achieve a great increase
in engagement or sales.
A classic example of this is Facebook and LinkedIn,
who discovered that, from X numbers of
users that the person puts on the network,
the network will continue.
Here you can think in points like
Oh, OK. I´ve already sold a video to this person,
if I offer him the next collection, maybe he will buy.
Or, if this person watched more than five videos,
it´s very likely that this person wants to buy.
If they have gone through five phases of the game, is very
likely that they want to buy the other.
And so on.